et puis le président chirac lui de
manifester pagenelle mais alors qu'il
recevait à l'elysée 150 personnalités du
monde de la culture
il a appelé à une mobilisation en faveur
du respect de la diversité culturelle
reportage véronique saint olive prendre
un verre ce qui nous permettra de
rencontrer de façon plus confortable
ils étaient une bonne centaine tout à
l'heure dans la grande salle des fêtes
de l'elysée veut d'être connus ou pas
star lierre et stars d'aujourd'hui tous
des professionnels de la culture et
jacques chirac reconnaît les siens à
quinze jours des négociations sont le
commerce mondial qui vont se dérouler
aux états unis jacques chirac appelle à
la rescousse
ceux qui refusent de considérer la
culture comme une marchandise parmi
d'autres ne s'agit pas bien entendu de
se complaire dans le rôle de david
contre goliath de diaboliser notre
partenaire américain ou de sombrer dans
le manichéisme
il s'agit simplement de rappeler qu'ils
ne petit avoir diversité culturelle sans
échange fait qu'il ne peut y avoir des
changes sont le respect de certains
équilibres de la france le président de
la république est enrhumé savoie
planches les sa détermination demeure
entière la culture ne peut pas se
standardiser un message une façon aussi
de rallier les artistes de tous bords
ces problèmes